Al righty I am back for another video
today we're going to be talking about
time series databases which shouldn't
take too long but um yeah just generally
the points I'm going to make in this
video I'm not going to talk about any
specific time series databases simply
just because I feel like in an interview
no interviewer is ever just going to be
like yeah so um tell me about how time
scale DB works I mean that would be like
way too specific cuz it's not that
popular um but I did abstract um you
know a couple of designed decisions away
from a few different time series
databases so what I might say doesn't
necessarily apply to every single time
series database but they did seem to be
good ideas that are in use in uh
multiple different types of them and as
a result that's kind of what I'm going
to be covering in this video so anyways
let's get into
that all righty so time series databases
well what are they in most applications
or most companies at one point or
another you're going to have to probably
store some sort of Time series data this
happens when you have log from a bunch
of servers sensors or any other type of
you know data that's coming in at a
consistent type of stream um over a time
interval uh as a result a bunch of
databases have actually been created
that are specifically tailored towards
this type of application um we'll go
over kind of the use cases of you know
what you might typically be doing when
dealing with time series data in the
first place but um overall it's
obviously good to use a specialized tool
for certain types of data whenever you
can and as a result that's why these
types of databases popped up so they're
really good for high read and write
throughput for specifically ordered time
series data and we'll talk about why
they work and you know kind of the
design decisions some of the creators
have made in order to kind of follow
through with that
promise so what are some time series
operations well in order to optimize for
the data we should definitely consider
the access patterns used in order to
basically make sure that all of those
access patterns are kind of being
handled by our design okay so rights
generally speaking the rights are going
to go to a recent time interval you know
like you're not going to get sensor
readings that are like 7 days late you
might get some that are a few minutes
late due to network delays but generally
speaking you're just writing things once
not updating them and you're inserting
them generally towards the end of a time
interval and then additionally keep in
mind that the adjacent values that
you're inserting from row to row are
probably going to be pretty similar if
it's something like a sensor reading for
example
uh one the time stamps are going to be
pretty similar and two whatever values
you're sharing probably didn't change
that much in the you know the small unit
of time so as a result um we have a
bunch of similar values next to one
another additionally um by using a
compound index like timestamp in
conjunction with some sort of data
source ID we can kind of Express you
know all of the metrics that we're
getting from a bunch of possible
different data sources and still be able
to cover all of those time and
um in terms of you know reads and kind
of the access patterns there generally
speaking um it's going to be from that
same timestamp data source combination
so just a tupal of those but just over
one column of data so maybe we have a
sensor that makes you know four readings
per timestamp generally speaking on
graphs we're probably only going to be
using one of those columns of data um
additionally they're all probably from a
relatively small time interval uh you
know you're not looking at years of data
generally speaking it's probably only
you know hours days weeks um and then in
terms of deletes the the most common
scenario is to you know take a bunch of
your older time series data say older
than 6 months and just start getting rid
of that you know it's it's not always
the case that people will hold hold this
analytics data for such a long
time okay so how would we go about
optimizing those rights well the first
thing is I kind of mentioned that um
it's very important that things are
sorted both on that time stamp value and
also on the kind of source ID where the
source might be either like you know the
server producing the logs or the sensor
producing a bunch of metrics but the
point is um time series data from the
same Source should be grouped together
and it should probably be ordered by the
time stamp itself so we now kind of have
this tupal that um provides like a very
natural compound index for us and so
this way when we have this we allow wrs
from the same data source over similar
intervals of time to be on the same node
assuming we're doing you know say some
type of sharding that way and you know
if we're sharding over multiple nodes or
even within one node as long as we're
keeping those rights together they
should be relatively
quick um in terms of optimizing reads um
a storing data in a column oriented
storage type is actually going to be
great because like I said generally
speaking you want to read probably one
column of data at a time and that means
that um in terms of performing
aggregations on the data uh having
column oriented storage makes that
really easy because all the data stored
together in one file it reduces a lot of
dis IO additionally since all those
values are going to be so similar over
you know the duration of one colum we
can do a ton of encoding on it so that
might be run length or bit map encoding
but the point is you know whatever
Library a Time series database does use
it can greatly reduce the amount of
storage that you need to be using by
virtue of using this compression
um okay and then in terms of optimizing
reads further uh this is something that
I saw that um was kind of unique to time
series data and I haven't seen it before
and so I'm going to go into a little bit
of depth on it so imagine that we have
uh as you can see in the bottom right
here we have this hypertable so
basically what a few of these databases
do is they represent all that time
series data on one node as one huge
table where that table represents both
you know uh time stamps and the source
ID and the point is it's kind of treated
as if it were this one huge table which
might insinuate that for that entire
table there's one continuous Index right
well actually instead what these
databases have chosen to do are abstract
away all of these things into the one
huge table which they call the
hypertable but really the hypertable is
made out of all these mini chunk tables
where chunk tables are a combination of
some sort of source and time interval
tupal so as you can see on the bottom
here I have these four chunks and each
one is just kind of a combination of a
time interval plus a you know a sensor
ID and so as a result of that there are
some huge benefits to this type of
design schema first of all since most
rights are only going to actually access
a couple of these at a time CU like I
said we're um kind of modifying things
that are only recent we can achieve much
better performance by caching the entire
index of only the relevant chunks in me
M for example if we had the entire hyper
table and we didn't have you know
smaller individual indexes what we would
have to end up doing is have this entire
huge B tree or all of these SS table
files and then we would have too much
index information to potentially have in
memory at once and we would constantly
be swapping in page files from disk in
and out to memory to you know access
them and change them and as a result
that would add a ton of overhead in
terms of doing that disc to memory swap
so so as a result by creating all of
these sets of smaller indexes we can
only keep the relevant small indexes in
memory and that hugely speeds up
performance additionally having uh this
chunking design as opposed to just one
huge table really helps by optimizing
deletes like I said it's a very common
use case that you kind of just want to
take a ton of old data and just wipe it
out because you no longer need it
anymore it's kind of past that time
threshold that it's relevant so by
breaking the main table into all these
chunks we can hugely improve the speed
of that exact operation why well if
think about like an LSM tree which we've
spoken about a lot in the past each
delete of data is its own right which
means it has to go into that inmemory
buffer and then you eventually add a
tombstone to an SS table file which
exists there until it's compacted and
then finally that key is deleted but if
we're writing a ton of deletes that's
going to be super inefficient instead it
would just be better if we actually just
deleted the entire index and just
dropped the file as a whole so that's
what we can do here here by using these
chunks you literally just delete the
chunk which is great and then the same
thing applies to berries if we were
doing a ton of deletes every single time
we deleted um a key value pair we would
have to go ahead and Traverse through
that b tree table and actually get rid
of the the key value or just you know
set the pointer to it to null whereas
now we can just go ahead and delete that
entire index so this is something that
um becomes much faster and it's actually
a pretty common thing that happens in
Time series
databases okay so I know this was a
short video but um in conclusion even
though storing time series data is not
something that you know every
application has to do all the time if
you are dealing with time series data
using a Time series specific database is
a really good way to go um between
creating separate indexes for each data
source and time interval you can take
advantage of really good cache
performance as well as the ability to
quickly delete things and also you know
just having a smaller index which makes
things really easy to write to because
you just write to the cache and then
Additionally the fact that all that data
is so similar means that using column
oriented storage can greatly reduce the
amount of storage space that you're
going to need as well as making it
really easy to do aggregations over some
sort of data so even though not every
time series database is identical these
are generally the main features of them
which allow them to handle this type of
data so well and so quickly so as a
result you know if it comes up in an
interview that you know you have some
sort of logging type of dat data then
you should definitely consider a Time
series database um like I said those
chunks are making a huge difference and
you know it's kind of unique because
it's the first time uh that we really
see partitioning within a single node
other than kind of using that fix size
partition schema that I've spoken about
a bit in the past this is actually a way
of using adaptive size chunks on a
single node and then obviously if you
were to scale out your time series
database in a distributed manner over
multiple nodes then you can probably
imagine that one way or another those
chunks would be put on different
machines and you know hashed somehow
okay guys so I hope you enjoyed the
video and uh hope it was useful um I'll
figure out what to do for tomorrow's but
uh I'll speak to you guys soon